their arrests were seen as political
statements at the time
now their mugshots have become iconic
symbols of the civil rights movement of
the 1960s
the freedom riders as they became known
traveled on buses throughout the summer
of 1961.
to parts of the southern united states
where segregation was still being
enforced
the riders were often met with outright
hostility in the form of violent attacks
by mobs and the klu klux klan
they also faced arrest and many spent
weeks in county jails
one of whom was 19 year old new yorker
louis zuckman
i was shackled taken from one from the
county jail
walking along with other prisoners and
the judge who had
sentenced me saw me and spit on me the
judge
so you began to realize how frightening
it was the bus was preceded by a
half-dozen highway patrol
car watching the first group of freedom
rides was lavonne brown from jackson
mississippi
at just 16 he was inspired to join the
movement which would later bring some
frightening moments
the clan came after us one night with
the help of the local police
and you know we sort of escaped by
jumping off the roof of a building next
to us
the clay came up the stairs the front
door we almost got killed
the freedom rider's treatment by local
authorities sparked a national
outcry eventually forcing the federal
government to act
and inspiring the wider civil rights
fight for the rest of the decade
lavon and i have been together with all
this stuff forever
zuckman and brown became friends lou and
i know each other so well
that we could go out and he could tell
my story i could tell anything both
zuckman and brown regularly appear
together to talk about their experiences
to a new generation one still grappling
with issues of systemic racism
everybody wants you know the big
explosion
and i mean it can be as simple as
putting your arm around somebody
that can be a revolutionary act
depending on where you are
even at 79 zuckman is still helping
minorities through his organization
scar harbor which supports disadvantaged
children in new york
one of the special things about the
freedom ride is it brought together
young people white african american male
female throughout america
it was a unique moment where we came
together as a country
we must end segregation in our schools a
moment that still resonates
60 years later kristen salumi al jazeera
new york